avec eugène berg ancien diplomate
spécialiste de la russie bonsoir aux
jeunes berg merci et à très vite sur rt
france c'est clairement un pari gagné
pour la dîmière poutine tout à fait
parce que comme on lit les pronostics ou
plutôt les les évaluations faites par
les meilleurs experts dont arnaud dubien
le directeur de l'observatoire franco
russe
il disait que où on voulait une
participation supérieure à 50% a été de
65 et à taux d'approbation d'alors de 70
il s'établit à 77,92 et même certains
sondages avant disait 75-76 donc ou
point de vue chiffres les résultats ont
été obtenus et participations et taux
d'approbation
alors c'est un amendement il faut le
préciser c'est important qui permettra
vadimir poutine de se représenter en
2024 mais aussi en 2030
oui ça c'est l'une des hypothèses
c'est disons l'une des discussions parmi
les 46 alors là aussi je crois qu'il
faut être avoir les pieds sur terre et
réalise l'ensemble de la presse a dit
voilà poutine avis c'est qu'ils
cherchent à se faire élire ses probables
personne lançait on le saura en 24 en
tout cas il ya encore quatre ans attend
de patience
ce qu'il veut surtout s être maître des
horloges maître du calendrier il a dit
lui-même
si moi je ne me présente pas et bien il
y aura une espèce de pression il y aura
une lutte d'influencé
les clans parce qu'ils existent partout
vont dégainer un petit peu et c'est pas
du tout favorable à la pierre actuelle
puisque il l'a dit il a dans son
interview avant la grande parade ce que
la russie cherche comme beaucoup de pays
c'est la stabilité la sécurité la
prospérité alors évidemment il est le
mieux placé pour assurer cette triade
mais en attendant il veut calmer le jeu
et il veut surtout savoir si
éventuellement il se représente 6 choisi
un successeur
pour l'instant quelques noms circulent
on a vu par exemple maire de moscou
sergueï sobianine qui d'ailleurs était
son son son secrétaire général c'était
le premier à il a très bien géré la
crise du colis de 19
il ya également le miz la défonce un
homme très proche populaire il y aurait
même un ancien collaborateur diatribe
holding donc il ya des noms qui
circulent mais prudence
son nom est loin le fait est que poutine
reste malgré d'ailleurs un taux
d'approbation qui a baissé là il faut le
dire
levada le centre indépendant a signalé
que son taux d'approbation est tombé de
79 60
c'est vrai que c'est bas mais pour un
dirigeant occidental c'est le rêve c'est
le paradis et attention ces sondages on
sait très bien ce qu en fonction de la
conjoncture
lala passé difficile pour tous les pays
pour la réussir en particulier puisqu'il
lui quand même cette chute des prix du
pétrole
il ya eu ce chômage maintenant il ya une
reprise dont le tourisme balbutie moi je
connais les agences de voyages qui ne
peuvent pas envoyer moi même je te veux
faire partie du groupe d'observateurs
internationaux ça a été annulé au
dernier moment donc voyez les
circonstances ne sont pas simples pour
la russie comme pour beaucoup de pays
en tout cas le résultat est là
l'opposition jeanne d'arc en tout cas de
dénoncent des irrégularités ils sont
dans leur rôle on imagine votre réaction
bon c'est vrai que les circonstances
n'ont pas été conformes je vais dire aux
normes de nouvielle démocraties
occidentales mais la russie ne se situe
pas là elle a fait les circonstances
étape extraordinaire
alors évidemment on peut se gausser on a
fait des jeunes dans les jardins dans
les caddies des supermarchés
voilà bon et est ce qu'il ya eu
manipulation
peut-être peut-être
et ça a été marginal donc peut-être
effectivement on peut gloser fini si
tous ces votes ont été un petit peu
arraché il ya eu des tombolas une des
choses comme ça mais c'est radicelles en
russie les gens battent comme ça et donc
je crois qu'il faut pas s'attacher
uniquement ça peut-être c'est une petite
tache mais elle cache pas l'ensemble des
résultats c'est ça qu'il faut voir
alors que des gens ne voient que la
petite tâche et ne voit pas le résultat
merci beaucoup aux jeunes d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france merci
à vous